then he pulls up to me and he's like
pull over I was like me me I didn't and
then he pulls us over and then he gives
us all the same ticket what the ticket
so when you're trying to get into the
left lane oh you can't be gay yeah you
can't be
[Music]
gay you guys ever heard about quing no
it sounds cool though what's that you
want you like it I like are you Pro
quing are you fishing for que I think
you're setting me up so yeah I [__]
am dude I love quing what's your
favorite thing
[__] the excitement you feel after
you do it and how it's a victimless
crime it doesn't hurt anybody no one
gets hurt it's totally fine I think
everyone should do it boys girls kids
everything I welcome quing I've been
quing since I was
12 12 I wish my parents qu me more I'm
in school for quing I want to get qu
what are we doing here I don't know what
this is quing is something that people
are trying to avoid why would that why
would cuz they're fools they're they're
closed mind they don't know the glory of
they probably think the Earth is round
didn't you ever got a good qu you know
what I mean what is it their first
experience was like just not coached
through well pushing is it's a scam yeah
well what is it it's something people do
where they put a QR code where there's
not supposed to be one so if you sat
down at like a diner and in the middle
you think that's the menu it's not some
guy put that QR code there so that you
scan it and you get your money stolen
smart oh my god dude send money to VMO
that's a [__] good SC I say something
though when I go to a restaurant and
they're like you could scan the QR code
there I'm pissed already I'm mad are you
like give me a paper menu yeah give me a
[__] paper men I know who you voted
for yeah dude because it's like it's
like just what's the point the pandemic
bro even the menu size went from are
menus are menus causing are menus
causing the co pandemic oh one of those
guys he's either tiger I'm [__]
saying it are menus causing the spread
of the Wuhan virus over here like I'll
take my
chances dude if I get Co from a menu I
kind of deserve that's true that means
I'm not sleeping well I'm not
exercising take it easy no IED probably
a fat
[__] take it easy there DT so it's um I
want Co through a menu so basically this
is our this is our uh PSA to everybody's
watching be careful with QR codes
because some of them what it'll do is it
might ask you to log into something it
might make you think that you're logged
out of your Google or something like
that you'll put your password and email
in like all that stuff and also there's
there's a couple that they have found
that actually find ways into your crypto
wallet and that's kind of the main way
that they see that's why I like analog
[__] that's what I'm saying bro keep it
old school why don't you have a [__]
rotary phone
on wait what's analog what are you
talking about just old school
[__] L like a menu oh [__] yeah QR
codes for men not [__] here SC scan
my eyeballs so I can order a [__]
pork chop just give me the menu dude I
do that Dad move now where I'm like yeah
we'll leave one menu here this the case
uh we got to
reord is that the dad the dad cuz when
you were young you were like oh let it
go yeah we'll keep it dad's like just
leave it there just in case we get a
little extra for some seconds they put
the Dig away another place to watch out
for these QR codes is parking garages so
any parking place like you know where it
says like oh you have to you got to pay
yourself and then leave your car there's
no attendant there's no like meter you
know something I do that's risky I never
pay for parking really I just leave my
car everywhere you'll get popped huh I
get so scar I've been doing that if you
do it for under an hour the chances are
not going to get but I've been doing the
uh emergency lights thing for the
Emergency license just leave it there
and just for that long go shopping yeah
that's tight especially when I go to
like a restaurant and stuff and it's get
gets crazy and I'm just like [__] thing
it's also different on what type of town
you're talking about if you're in
downtown you have like no shot that's
what I'm saying in downtown I do it like
you know that's part of you know you
know why cuz I know that people be lazy
and if it's that's a that's a shirt
right there people be lazy if it's 6:00
a.m. on a Sunday you know that a meter
mate isn't going to be there I feel like
I got the worst luck I don't know man
this dude this dude crossed the street
and got a freaking I get the worst Lu i'
yeah same thing I've like [__] paid a
meter and then like on the minute it
expired I swear that [__] was just
standing waiting for the clock to go
down just it is no it is like cheap
sometimes it's more cost effective like
when I was uh had my uh studio in
downtown I never paid for parking ever
because the chances I'm going to get a
ticket I would still be saving money
versus if I paid the meter every time or
if I paid for monthly parking see risk
analysis and I would get tickets I would
get them but then when you do the math
it's like oh it's cheaper to just get
tickets sometimes wow sometimes I I do
be uh like taking a risk like I be
living I just go off a logic I'm like
well uh look where I'm at no one's going
to come in here just leave the doors
open or like not unlock it like if I cuz
if I oh I forgot to lock it I'm like you
know what where am I at bo bo I think
I'll be fine and I'll leave and I'll
just but I my girl's always like you got
to you can't you can't trust and I'm
like [__] I know what I'm doing I know
what I'm doing and you know what's a
good idea I never did this before but
just in case anyone wants to know what a
good idea is if you want free parking
you know those meters just carry a bag
around and write broken on it and put it
over the mirror
who that's a good [__] move I never
did that I don't recommend people to do
it Joe's the guy who [__] carries
cones in his trunk and he always just
parks and then he puts [__] con con
are smart bro I am the king of just move
the [__] cone and park there if they
have cones already I just [__] get
off and I move and the construction
thing falls on your face yeah I know
right yeah dude I always [__] just
move the cone and just I don't give a
[__] but you guys are kind of ballsy
dude you guys kind of badasses or did
you ever do the move where like you put
cone you ever put like a shirt on the
passeng your car and just do the car
pulling a shirt dude I not even a hat
bro I just do the car pulling all the
time oh really I you never got never got
caught I got caught one time but it's
kind of it's kind of like the just save
time yeah just pay the hard I I do the
uh I always get I I have a Arizona
license plate oh do you yeah and I
always do the I'm not I'm not allowed to
do that I always play Dum the dumb
they're just like like yeah you can't go
to the carpool L I don't we don't have
carpool in Arizona well [__] you can't
do it I said you can't be you got to
have another person that's all they
talking California I didn't know yeah oh
wait wasn't didn't Arizona have a really
big uh problem with like speed cameras
or like cameras for oh I don't know I
was living in California BN oh ear
Arizon take it easy dude I drove for I
drove in Arizona for like 3 years and
then I moved out here cuz you know how
we had the we had a really big problem
with the red light cameras it was a pain
in the ass well you know you know why
you know why they took it away though
right know it's illegal no you know why
why well yes you go now but do you know
why why you guys want to know another
fun fact please tell us please reason
why please please huh tell us the reason
why is that I sued the state because he
got caught and had to get a divorce
because he had a side chick on his
passenger seat and that was illegal it's
invasion of privacy and they took they
send that they sentent it to you the
picture to your [__] his wife wife
opened it and said wait wait [__] all
that who's that [__] and then he got
caught another thing he had to get a
divorce and pay all this money for a
divorce all because of this camera yeah
he sued the [__] and another reason
why is because it's actually technically
not legal like because actual officer
has to catch you in the act and inite
you they they can't just keep it uh
recording and on top of that there they
the cities there's something called a
snitch ticket where if you actually
didn't like run the red but then it was
like you stopped and then made a right
which is what I did I looked it up they
just [__] send out tickets yeah
because they're hoping that you just pay
and you don't fight it yeah but then all
I had to do is show up for court and
they go all right they went through this
whole name they're like um if you're
here today and your name is on the list
you could leave and I got my refund and
I was like that was a big [__] waste
of time but it's because this that you
know they were just B basically making a
hell of money on people doing that too
that's why a lot of people were like
[__] this have you guys ever got pulled
over but with multiple other people like
with a bunch of like other cars for the
same violation oh no that's weird I got
I got pulled over with three four other
cars got like C wrangled yeah I got they
all four of you in front like that dude
the [__] cop was I I thought he was
pulling over I thought he was pulling
over everyone else but he started
pulling over he came up he pulled over
two people behind me and I was like damn
that sucks then he pulls up to me and
he's like pull over I was like me me I
didn't and then he pulls us over and
then he gives us all the same ticket
what was the ticket so when you're
trying to get into the left lane oh you
can't be gay yeah you can't be gay he
was did he he did this oh my God oh my
God I bite my lip too hard while I was
turning he saw the
cop oh my God I'm sorry we like rose on
the window pull over
where I was bite my finger going left
while gay but we crossed we all crossed
the yellow line to make the the the
green left turning light oh but I was
like go [__] yourself
yeah but I was mad cuz I was like I was
like okay I got got I got got with five
other people it is what it is how much
was that ticket I was like gang 350 for
that oh my God you're the only person I
know that has a jaywalking tick I know
bro you know how [__] frustrating
that
ISU at 6:00 a.m. dude oh dud that's
crazy he saw you as a fool he's like oh
this [__] not going to fight I I
was inside the coffee shop and I was
like what kind of should I get an today
maybe you were walking gay there too
dude I'll sip in my cappuccino 6 a.m.
probably the F pack bro I've been lying
this guy Taps me on the shoulder pulls
me out I'm like what can I help you with
officer and he's like here you go and
I'm like what paying this huh you know
which just an expensive tip I'm a cck
I'm a [__] C I can't believe that
happened maybe cuz you're in Pasadena
you got actual cops that write tickets
all day oh oh yeah I got a ticket for
[__] exposing myself in Pasadena yeah
I think you should get a ticket for
exposing yourself anytime I don't think
so I don't think so are you a sex
offender are you a sex offender now was
to De School no no no no no but I pull
my dig out and I was taking a piss and
the cop just and I'm like hey no no no
no no you can't be I'm like come on guys
come on not in Pasadena man roughy I was
drinking a little bit all you should be
able piss you should be able to pee a
little bit but I you know you know
what's an expensive ticket that I never
thought was going to be expensive was uh
I got it it was like $600 and something
doar if you're if you go through like a
in the in intersection and you switch
lanes inside the intersection that's
$600
600 for that I was like I was like why
is it so expensive cuz it's what causes
most of the accidents cuz some gu trying
to turn and you go into a little lane
but I'm literally like going in and then
yeah in the middle of the intersection I
just like switch lanes and they're like
you can't do yeah 600 you got to pass
the light and make that thing you know
what a do you know what a California
rule is oh they're delicious when you
when you don't stop at the stop sign
long enough oh that's a to California
roll yeah cuz you you kind of just roll
real quick avocado and yeah I love my
favorite that was my first uh sushi that
was my last actual ticket o I think I
did was my last ticket in front of a cop
dang I didn't stop long enough you got
to go abc123 and then you can
go
pap